so Donald Trump you have now sided with
another dictator against the United
States and people probably didn't hear
about it because one were 16 months now
you have generated a dozen stories a day
that would have caused any other
candidate to withdraw and flee to the
Caymans and to you have almost run out
of new dictators to praise I'm going to
let the viewer here try to guess who the
new addition to your roster is we know
it cannot be Kim jong-un you already
praised him last January if you look at
North Korea this guy I mean he's like a
maniac okay and you got to give him
credit how many young guys he was like
26 or 25 when his father died take over
these tough generals and all of a sudden
you know it's pretty amazing when you
think of it how does he do that he goes
in he takes over and he's the boss it's
incredible he wiped out the uncle he
wiped out this one that one I mean this
guy doesn't play games incredible
amazing you got to give him credit sure
you do Trump if you are more interest in
a despot killing people the way Stalin
used to kill people then you are
interested in us and how we deal with a
psychopath who rules his country on the
premise that he will eventually stage
nuclear war against this country so the
new guys not kim jeong-hoon so Putin why
can't be Putin can it Trump three weeks
ago Homeland Security and the DNI said
that the intelligence community is quote
confident that the Russian government
directed the recent compromises of
emails from US persons and institutions
including from u.s. political
organizations in simpler language for
you Trump the Russians hacked us
just like you invited them to at your
last news conference and our national
security people told you that and
presumably in much more detail and then
Hillary Clinton brings it up in the last
debate and you say she has no idea
whether it's Russia China or anybody
else our country has no idea she then
explains it and you interrupt you to say
I doubt it
so you've said Putin and Russia are
probably right and our intelligence
agencies are probably wrong how many
times is that that you've defended Putin
and Russia Trump I have lost count and
how many times have you praised Putin
over Obama over Clinton just
this week you did it again you told
Reuters how is she going to go back and
negotiate with this man who she has made
to be so evil made to be so evil he is
evil you disloyal bastard so the new
strongman whose side you have taken is
not Russian Chinese maybe now I already
praised them 26 years ago in Playboy
when the students poured into Tiananmen
Square the Chinese government almost
blew it then they were vicious they were
horrible but they put it down with
strength that shows you the power of
strength if you're an actual American
Trump after you call the Chinese at
Tiananmen Square vicious and horrible
there is no but there's just vicious and
horrible Trump so is it Saddam Hussein
well no you already praised him to July
you know what he did well he killed
terrorists he did that so good they
didn't read them the rights they didn't
talk they were a terrorist it was over
once again Trump your stupidity about
authoritarian regimes past or present is
rivaled only by your naivete if somehow
the only people Sodom who saying killed
in Iraq were terrorists then what you
said might make some kind of sense but
he killed or disappeared at least
200,000 of his own citizens I'm guessing
the children he killed probably weren't
terrorists Trump so your new candidate
for BFF among the dictators isn't Iraqi
but topically we've actually finally
gotten warm Rodrigo Duterte
the lunatic elected in the Philippines
on a mandate of shooting first and
asking questions later about possible
drug dealers possible drug addicts
basically anybody he thinks should die
now without a trial or often without an
arrest approximately 3,000 dead in his
first hundred days in office Oh in in
August Trump this buffoon claimed he
told Secretary of State Kerry that quote
your ambassador is a gay son of a [ __ ]
unquote and a month later he said a
President Obama son of a prostitute
I swear at you so now in an interview
with Reuters who did you blame for this
murderer Duterte insulting our leaders
and damaging his country's relationship
with us
him of course not he's showing power
right Trump only you Trump could blame
this on Obama because you think our
president quote wants to focus on his
golf game rather than engage with these
tyrants so it's Obama's fault that
Duterte showed again quoting you a lack
of respect for our country our country
Trump I hear that and I think which
country do you view as your country as
our country for all the flag hugging
figurative and literal when it's North
Korea versus the US you side with North
Korea when it's Russia versus the US you
side with Russia when it's China versus
the US you side with China when it's
Iraq versus the u.s. you side with Iraq
and now when it's the Philippines versus
the US you side with the Philippines
Trump I've asked this before and I have
to ask it again are you loyal to the
United States of America that's the
closer I'm Keith Olbermann watch this
space